bonsoir la police resserre son étau sur
le milieu nationaliste corse après un
premier coup de filet hier elle a
procédé à deux nouvelles interpellations
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de l'enquête
sur l'assassinat du préfet Erignac la
police qui posséderait de nouvelles
pistes de nouveaux éléments le point
avec Christophe Bardy
et explication de Christophe Bardy sans
doute dans un instant sur cette série
d'interpellations qui a commencé hier et
qui s'est procédé aujourd'hui la sœur
d'Allah Ferrandi a finalement été
entendu cet après-midi par les
enquêteurs de l'hôtel de police
d'Ajaccio audition également des parents
du nationaliste corse ce matin ce qui
porte à 11 le nombre des interpellations
en 48 heures hier la police procédait en
effet à l'arrestation d'Alain Ferrandi
ainsi que de 6 de ses proches fait Randy
qui est aux yeux des forces de l'ordre
le chef d'un groupe nationaliste en
Corse du Sud mais il est surtout
infidèle de Jean Castella un autre
nationaliste incarcéré en novembre 98
les deux hommes font figure de
principaux suspects dans l'assassinat du
presse Erignac le 6 février 98 ils
auraient conversé avec leur portable le
soir même du meurtre aussi bien avant
qu'après l'acte la police a d'ailleurs
saisi hier des listings de leurs appels
les dernières arrestations encore
s'inscrivent dans le le cadre d'une
enquête longue et périlleuse c'est à
partir de l'arme du crime retrouvée sur
les lieux que les policiers ont d'abord
expliqué les attentats de pietrozzella
de Vichy et de Strasbourg perpétré
quelques mois auparavant ses attentats
auraient selon toutes vraisemblance
servie à préparer le meurtre du préfet
la piste agricole est alors explorée
elle permettra l'arrestation de deux
hommes à commencer par Marcel Lorenzoni
à partir de cet arrestation et des
multiples auditions qui suivront un
deuxième homme est arrêté Matthieu
philidori c'était jeudi dernier il a été
mis en examen pour complicité
d'assassinat il est accusé d'être
l'auteur de plusieurs revendications
d'actes terroristes bref la justice à ce
soir le sentiment d'avoir cerné